[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
had it it's too much pressure
[Applause]
[Music]
America is burger nirvana but to truly
appreciate what it has to offer
you've got to hit the road there are so
many regional burgers out that we've
barely scratched the surface to get a
glimpse of the past this place is the
most historically significant hamburger
restaurant in America and gain insight
into the future I don't think any chef
has ever gone up against a robot to me
Oh a burger moment of truth man versus
machine Alva kai-lan for the burger show
the Creator I'm on a mission to expand
my burger horizons and I'm calling on
some friends old and new to help me
along the way we're gonna try and debunk
a few burger myths don't salt your
patties before you grind it look if you
look at an onion there's two different
ways you can cut it this is like a Jedi
Yoda moment
now is she ready for this I'm tired I'm
a hungry I'm hungover well this burger
we sort of call the Lacey edge burger
can we call it the Lisa Stasi
shut up Stacy I don't think you can
compare that to a regular cheeseburger
you just can't that is insane if you
thought the steamed cheeseburger or
something else when you see this thing
cheers man
nuts solid record ood fella whoa that's
way different the burger force is really
with you let's eat